Terry what did director Park teach you
about filmmaking well rather than teach
me something there was a lot of
conversations taking place we met
together we first met while he was still
rewriting his script so a lot of
conversation took place and I felt like
I was going along this process with him
right from the beginning did you know
that you had been chosen among 1500
other young women did you know that
during the audition process I only found
out a little bit I knew that there were
many but as to the exact number I found
only later on at what point did you know
the sexual nature and the nudity in the
film would be part of your role a very
prominent part during the audition
process that Clark showed me a copy of
the script so I found that and I have to
ask were you terrified or was this a
challenge that you wanted to take on a
little bit of both well I had to think
about it paulus hair is quite troubling
at the beginning but after a lot of
contemplation to which I was able to
convince myself that this was what's
required for the character I was able to
from that point on go along with it
without any help
director Park how did you make it
comfortable for the actors on set
knowing that this is a very integral
part of the movie and very beautifully
done but also could be very
uncomfortable at parts for them how did
you make it so that the set was more
comfortable either a clothes that keep
it light make jokes how did you do it
there was no jokester who would make to
try and make that if you have the time
to making jokes you use that time to
proceed quickly what's most important
not what happens on the set but during
what happens during
pre-production what you do during that
stage is the most important thing and
when I approach these these kinds of
things it's not just about but not just
in the writing of the script but I do I
tend to do a thorough storyboard and
through the through the storyboarding
stage I plan things as to Suffolk and
detailed as possible through doing
things that way the actors are able to
see exactly what to expect for those
things because they see it on the page
and they are able to be prepared
mentally going into those things and
when the time comes when you get to it
onset the most important thing is to do
it quickly and get over that with
director Park I believe you said
previously that you're not the kind of
filmmaker that aims to send a message
although you're not opposed to it so
then what makes you decide to take on a
certain project well it's all it all
depends on how much the story pulls me
into it how much I'm Mesmer mesmerized
by the story what I feel about any given
story in terms of how I respond to it
instinctively is the most important
thing for me for this project however
it's a slightly different from that from
that case this is a film with certainly
a message something to say because this
film had the message destroying had the
message where the woman who had been
oppressed by the hora balanced male gaze
through solidarity forming solidarity
between the two they are able to escape
from it was the crux of the story